sa venue installer la le festivoix de
trois rivières et le premier grand
événement à sauter dans l'arène ou de
fébrilité
parce que ça fait un petit moment qu'on
va pas monter notre festival un
événement qui propose habituellement des
spectacles sur scène pour environ trois
cent mille visiteurs
il sera réduit à trois scènes pour un
maximum de 10 mille festivaliers
dans notre cas nous on pourra pas se
rendre à plus de 1500 personnes sur
l'ensemble de ce fini les passeports
donnant accès aux lieux librement espace
pour délimiter les sièges horaires de
spectacle décalé tout pour respecter les
règles de la santé publique pc encore
beaucoup d'ajustements dernière minute
parce que les couleurs des zones change
même que la santé publique a annoncé
cette semaine que les événements
pouvaient recevoir 3500 personnes soit
mille de plus qu'il y a à peine quelques
jours donc on va rouler ici le salon des
rats chevaline la plus grande exposition
agricole c'est de saint-hyacinthe reçoit
habituellement deux cent mille visiteurs
avec les mesures sanitaires en place
mais on peut aller jusqu'à 7500 par jour
parce qu'on a divisés note dans le fond
entre oye plage horaire avec un maximum
de 2500 donc ça tourne autour de 30
mille personnes étalé sur quatre jours
au lieu de 10 les activités seront elles
rentables
si la vente d'accès se passe bien oui on
va avoir un événement serré type de mal
et chaque chaque s'ouvre être comptés
ils vont être les promoteurs qui vont
réussir à faire de l'argent cette année
c'est pourquoi le ministère québécois du
tourisme à bonifier ses programmes d
aide de 15 millions de dollars sur deux
ans et le fédéral a réservé une
enveloppe de 400 millions de dollars
pour les festivals et événements ça
vient combler une partie la réalité mais
les revenus autonomes qui se calcule en
billetterie à concessions alimentaires
sains produits dérivés ça ça va ça va
manquer ce qui ne devrait pas manquer ce
sont les festivaliers on attend
longtemps
oui beaucoup ça m'a manqué l'année
passée pour que le coeur du québec bat à
nouveau
il sait marie-josée paquet comme ou
radio canada montréal